[Music]
meagan marvel it seems her wedding day
to Prince Harry is merely a formality
she's already stepping out for royal
events but today was her first official
one with the Queen
[Music]
meagan singing god save the queen'
attended the Commonwealth Day service at
Westminster Abbey this afternoon a
significant event because it's the
Queen's first public acknowledgement of
Megan and her place in the royal family
by contrast Megan's sister-in-law-to-be
Kate Middleton didn't attend any
official events with the royal family
before she was married in Prince Harry
and Megan who are set to Wed on May 19th
arrived with Harry's brother William and
Kate who's due to deliver their third
child next month the Fab Four walked in
just ahead of the Queen and Megan's
future father-in-law
Prince Charles Megan and the Duchess
were color-coordinated Megan in an
almost $1200 cream coat and navy blue
dress both by British designer Amanda
Wakeley Kate in all Navy recycling her
$900 Beulah London coat that she wore
during her last pregnancy
One Direction er Liam Payne performed
during the interfaith service
recognizing members of the Commonwealth
nations Megan and Harry who shared a few
sweet moments during the service will
have a major role in the Commonwealth
once she officially joins the family
change
[Music]